in the course road trip
you start with step one
admit
how do you do that how do you how do you
kind of step back and
do that inventory yeah
is there a trick to that
oh if there's a trick to it I think it's
just about courage
of having them
because it's
I don't think any of us like to admit
our lives or look deep enough in the go
I've relied so much on that lie that has
become my reality
yeah and I'm and I and I I don't want to
be
so puritanical
as I say
again that's why I say admit instead of
Judge
but I don't want to be so puritanical as
to go
and admit it and get rid of it no I'm
just saying to admit it just bring it to
the surface
yeah
um
saying this and I'm
doing something different
preached this but I actually my actions
just admit it
just just admit though just admit them
and
I think that's the first step to where
we
begin to
either forgive ourself and give
ourselves some amnesty and go yeah I'm a
human trying to make it through life as
best I can I'm gonna let myself slide on
that one okay and maybe I've been
getting away with it for so long whole
family my whole network works well on it
okay forget this get to the base of the
truth of the matter let me do it but
just admit it
and then where will and then it will
also help it'll be easier to then expose
to ourselves which ones we go
no
I'm not letting myself slide on that
anymore that is actually a lie I've been
believing that's been keeping me from
getting more of what I want in life
that's actually a lie I've been living
that I haven't admitted that
is not allowing me to enjoy life as much
as
I damn well should be
deserve to be or have earned to be or
just sort of let myself
you've been add-on it's it's not all the
hard stuff sometimes it can be a a a a
fun thing on top about how many times do
we major in our minors let's admit where
we sit there and we go
all right I give myself 12-hour work day
but I noticed I'm spending eight on my
hobbies and four on my career
well I'm majoring in my minors
huh let me admit that there's the math
why don't we invert that how about four
hours on my hobbies and eight on my
career
first off just admitting it allows me to
go now I can do the math or rearrange
the math by time of day
but I I look I just found a hobby tennis
first topic I've had in 25 years
I had to admit that I that I went to
play tennis for this started to love it
for the first month
I started feeling guilty
I was like I'm happy is it okay to have
this much fun I'm having so much fun and
I'm getting a great workout
yes it's okay
congratulations bro you found something
that is you're finding quite
pleasurable
for straight pleasure
you don't have to forget all this other
stuff but yeah but I'm also getting a
workout we're getting that too but don't
just you don't have to excuse the
pleasure based on oh but it's it's good
for you and you're gonna now you damn it
the real reason you love is because you
you're having so much damn fun at it I
had to admit that to let myself go damn
right I'm going to play tennis again
today or tomorrow it was a simple fun
thing
so it's not always about the hardcore
stuff that we have to go
this is a deep dark lie that I've been
living by and it's having me live fosty
and it's having harmful consequences on
my loved ones
some of those will probably arise and we
admit
I think he's just having a look around
and just saying
and when we admit it
then we go when we admit a lie
then we become something much more
valuable
a bullshitter
yeah you had a little wink in your eye I
love the distinction I'm bullshitting
myself on that thing yep I'm lying
therefore if I call it a lion yep well
nap me up I'm bullshitting you now she's
out didn't judge it
but now I'm bullshitting that I think we
can work with